so you want to start reading deadpool
comics i did a review of the deadpool
game from 2013 a few years ago and ever
since i've gotten tons and tons of
questions about where to start reading
the character
for a while i would just send them this
list i made but even then it leaves them
still unsure of what to expect from each
run beyond these short descriptions
so i figured i'd give a handy guide for
the characters so far and what each part
of his history is like so anyone can
jump in at the stuff that's best suited
for them
remember to support your local comic
shops kids
someone keep a counter of how many times
i actually say the word deadpool in this
video i wanna see there's so much about
deadpool to know like he doesn't like
chimichangas he was thor once for an
afternoon kind of he has an evil clone
made of spare parts or he's bawled by
choice because his hair grows back in
patches if you can relate to that last
part because you're a mutant assassin
with a very derivative name and costume
designed with grooming issues then you
have to try out manscaped he's got a
nice pair of smooth criminals going
under this video is brought to you by
manscape.com the global brand for men's
grooming and hygiene products
manscaped offers the best tools and
liquid formulations for the big three
odor zones your body butt and balls to
get a feel for the quality of their
lovely products manscape sent yours
truly their new all-in-one performance
package 4.0 i've always been a pretty
clean-cut guy if you know what i mean
but sometimes the old scissors and razor
can be a bit nerve-racking near the
delicates so it was especially nice to
try out the new lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer this is manscaped 4th generation
electric waterproof trimmer with
advanced skin safe technology which
reduces nicks and cuts on the most
sensitive region of the body
you can twist this thing around at any
angle and i can guarantee you you cannot
hurt your tender manhood with it it's
very safe and easy to use and look a
light so you can see what you're doing
down there instead of fiddling around
like you're trying to change a tire in a
dark garage with the handy cordless
charging dock and three click travel
lock you can keep your dangly parts
smooth and clean on the go also included
in the performance package 4.0 are the
crop preserver ball deodorant and crop
reviver ball toner spray simply apply
the crop preserver after your shower for
all day body order protection the crop
reviver is a convenient spritz with
cooling aloe vera to quickly refresh the
area whenever you need it keep
everything smelling all nice manscaped
really has you covered from head to toe
this is their weed whacker nose and ear
hair trimmer it's a wireless nose
trimmer with the same skin safe
technology is the groin trimmer so you
don't have to worry about tugging or
cutting on those sensitive nose hairs
for limited time you get all this plus
two free gifts the shed travel bag and
the manscaped anti-chafing boxer briefs
go to manscape.com today and get 20 off
plus free international shipping plus
two free gifts when you use the promo
code godzilla manscaped always use the
right tools for the job now back to the
video deadpool for a long time was one
of marvel's more obscure and niche
characters he's a wisecracking mercenary
assassin that's hideously disfigured and
has but one superpower he cannot be
killed and will heal from any wound
except the emotional ones but i think
his popularity has grown enough now
between his two big screen theatrical
outings and bazillion appearances and
games and tv
that he really needs no introduction
maybe you know him from that taco
tuesday shirt you saw at the hot topic
that no one would ever wear and if they
did
they were me i've made my point already
about how much i resent the way he's
been flanderized to the point of
becoming synonymous with random meme
culture so i'll try to refrain from
bitching about that and just focus on
what i love about the character instead
i like being positive i like making
videos on stuff i like
the angry videos about things i hate are
more popular though alright let's get
the basics out of the way deadpool's
first appearance in new mutants number
98 the beautiful land of the 90s where
every character was drawn with three
thousand percent more lines on their
face so everyone looked really elderly
even if they were kids it's not a super
character defining important issue for
learning who he is but at least
establishes the long-running history of
enemies to friends to frenemies to maybe
lovers that he has with cable the x-men
version of kyle reese the art is exactly
what you've heard about it but the
writing is at least some fun cheesy 90s
dialogue by fabian nishini
who made deadpool edgy and wisecracking
to distinguish him from the long line of
characters he's a rip-off from after
various scattered appearances and new
mutants and a little bit of x-force he
slowly became less of a villain and more
of an anti-hero an interest grew until
he got his first miniseries deadpool the
circle chase it's still written by
nicieza but with some really nice
pencils by joe maduraire medurk meh
pronounced madurai you [ __ ] idiot
it's not the best but it establishes
deadpool's friendship with his sidekick
and resident tech guy weasel as well as
his short-lived and not well-developed
rivalry with black tom cassidy you
killed black tom you racist son of a
[ __ ] it's also the first of many
attempts to dig into deadpool's
backstory as a serious and stoic
mercenary who leaves his girlfriend
vanessa to find a cure for his terminal
cancer resulting in him getting
superpowers
and also tortured
she also eventually becomes a blue
shape-shifting mutant like mystique and
as copycat she violently resents
deadpool for leaving and wants some
revenge but also kinda wanna kiss and
make up too
it's complicated his second mini-series
written by mark wade deadpool's sins of
the past not that one this one further
establishes some characters that will be
important to deadpool lore like the mad
scientist dr killbrew that gave deadpool
his powers who got cut from the movie
and the mutant irish woman named siren
that deadpool has a creepy stalkery
crush on which will lead to terrible
terrible things it's also the first time
we get to see him unmasked in all his
gory glory it's alright i guess i'm not
the biggest fan of any of these three
major early stories but if you're trying
to get the hang of the character they're
important but keep in mind they feel
mostly like homework just to get the
cast and the concept down i'd say the
first legitimately really good deadpool
run is his first solo ongoing from 1997
by joe kelly one of the founders of the
group man of action that would go on to
create ben 10 and generator rex
now that's a weird crossover but joe
kelly and ed mcguinness work on this
first run is way better than it had any
right to be this really shows the kind
of creative freedom allowed on obscure
characters there wasn't a firmly
established idea of deadpool until this
book in my opinion and all the books
with him later on are working off of
what was pioneered here
it's the day-to-day adventures of
deadpool which are
shockingly sad and uncomfortable his
friendships with other mercenaries are
toxic and antagonistic his housemate
blind al is not a wisecracking roommate
but a hostage held against her will and
forced to maintain his home while he's
on missions under threat of torture and
possibly death joe kelly portrays
deadpool as a full-on villain here doing
some extremely immoral things daily by
the start of the story but the first
issue of the series finds deadpool in a
situation where if he doesn't intervene
thousands of people could die and it
forces him to commit the first really
selfless act of his life and the feeling
of that personal sacrifice sets things
in motion
suddenly he starts feeling guilty about
all the terrible things he's doing and
it also generates some more concrete
consequences when he discovers his
healing powers are shutting down his
series then follows the path of deadpool
learning to be a better person to those
around him trying to reignite his
failing superpowers and
leading him back to some uncomfortable
parts of his past and discovering why
this shady government military group is
watching him and telling him he might be
some kind of prophecy chosen one to save
the world be sure to read the deadpool
and death 98 issue that goes in between
here and the daredevil crossovers to get
the full picture the latter of which is
the basis for much of the first movie
the art for this series defines the look
for deadpool going forward and the
writing really solidifies everything you
need to know about the character
except for the ending of the run i'll
just let you know before going in the
ending of this run tries to establish a
really strange and controversial twist
for deadpool's backstory
it's not necessarily a retcon because
it's some of deadpool's first stories so
it was more of an original idea for him
but
in a very complicated way the book tries
to suggest that wade wilson is a fake
name that deadpool stole at some point
just know
that's been retconned to oblivion by
just about every writer after joe kelly
and there's so much evidence against it
now as well as the character asserting
that being a lying villain who wanted to
mess with deadpool's head
that you can pretty much just blow it
off if you try to make sense of that
story and fit it in with everything else
we know about deadpool's past you'll
drive yourself crazy because it doesn't
really fit anywhere it was a big
stunning twist for joe kelly to end his
run on and it wasn't really stepping on
the toes of anything that came before it
because nothing came before it
but it ended up complicating the
character so much in making him so evil
that
reasonably many people choose not to
give it much thought it wouldn't be the
last story kelly would write for the
character but it's unfortunate that his
legendary run
ends with something so shaky that
ultimately ended up not really mattering
i can comfortably say that the following
writers of the series
were a poor choice and didn't contribute
much to deadpool's history that's worth
really looking into christopher priest
and paco diaz's short-lived term on
deadpool had him getting kidnapped by
loki being falsely led to believe loki
as his father is part of a plot to mess
with thor and then he's cursed by loki
to have tom cruise's face yes actually
tom cruise they spelled it wrong to
avoid legal trouble they always do that
but just
just look at him he goes and lives with
two other super villains in an apartment
and it turns into a weird kind of super
villain sitcom
where deadpool becomes the straight man
while everything else around him is
absurd and comical and he's just tired
and grouchy it's really weird and a lot
of this goofy stuff is happening as an
attempt to give another window into
deadpool's childhood but much like the
joe kelly run all of this would later be
discounted entirely and i don't mind
because it's not that compelling or
original i will say however that the
dialogue is at least really funny and it
still gets a laugh out of me
so it has that going for it if you want
something funny that you could kind of
just pretend is not canon then
yeah
but these books aren't super important
for knowing the full scope of the
character it's kind of a weird aside
you can skip these issues and just go
straight to issue 46. now the team of
writers will switch around a lot but
these are generally really solid
deadpool stories with a nice balance of
the dark and funny tone it's kind of
ironic there's a book in here where he
gets buried alive you can stick with
this all the way until the final issue
in the original deadpool series
issue 69
i guess that couldn't be more fitting
gail simone's final arc for the series
sees deadpool accidentally becoming a
very famous and well-respected mercenary
after assassinating five deadly crime
bosses while falling through a skylight
but this leads him to a rivalry with a
more old school assassin named the black
swan who wants to destroy deadpool from
the inside out the art in this portion
of the series by the guys at udon
entertainment is fantastic it's a nice
blend of realism and this sort of manga
influence style it ends on an
interesting cliffhanger that makes you
wonder if deadpool might have been
finally killed because he's a character
barely anyone knew about he managed to
make it almost 70 issues though so his
fan base was small but really dedicated
this cliffhanger is resolved in
agent x
yes this is actually crucial deadpool
reading this guy you've never heard of
agent x looks kind of like deadpool acts
like deadpool except a bit nicer and
more ambitious with his career
uh and has similar skills to deadpool
but he doesn't know who he is everyone
assumes he might be deadpool but they
aren't sure either and ended up just
treating him as a new guy named alex
hayden aka agent x
the udon art and gail simone writing
continue and this is a really fun mini
series that sets up some great recurring
characters from the next few deadpool
arcs
and it ultimately has a really great
payoff i wish this part of the history
was more well known and alex hayden
would be brought back in more books
because he's great at the very least he
should be an alternate costume for
deadpool and video games going forward
now our boy is in his first shared
ongoing with cable not much to say about
this one other than it it's it's really
good it's fabian nisieza's best work
with the character his bromance slash
burning hatred of cable is really well
developed
it introduces a few jokes side
characters and running gags that became
synonymous with the character
i would say a lot of what people know
about deadpool came from this run hey
look ironically this is the first issue
of the book that ryan reynolds ever read
this is in 2004. i didn't know who
deadpool was and he said trust me if
they ever make a movie about deadpool
you're the only guy that can play
deadpool um the first uh issue i opened
up i not making this up i was on the
panel like somebody asked him what he
looks like he says i look like a cross
between ryan reynolds and a sharpay it's
just a must read for deadpool fans
although ironically deadpool sort of
takes over the series and cable becomes
a less and less important part of the
run
until he just disappears entirely for a
little bit and it's just a deadpool book
that heavily references cable
this is sort of symbolic of the
character's popularity with time because
cable is never meant to be this guy's
sidekick
if anything it was supposed to be the
other way around
look they even switched their names on
the future crossovers the way deadpool
is drawn in the series has really stuck
with the character and become his most
definitive look with the pointy hood on
the back and the seams on his mask
eventually being translated into the
live-action movie costume i think these
were good changes because they really
helped to further distinguish him from
being like a ninja spider-man they're
subtle but they help finally we get to
the stuff that a lot of people are mixed
about
i'm going way out of order here but
it'll help clarify some canon things so
you aren't confused like i was
deadpool annual number one from 2013
explains why for a while he had an extra
voice in his head with a different color
and font just like
uh read these pages
then stop
then read this wolverine arc this is the
first story that really explored
wolverine in deadpool's relationship
and it was writer daniel way's backdoor
pilot for his own deadpool run which is
arguably one of if not the most
influential one after that wolverine arc
start with deadpool vol 2 2008 it's
entirely written by daniel way with a
rotating but relatively consistent art
team for 63 issues this run tries to
redefine wilson's origin yet again but
it gets strangely muddled and confusing
again the strengths of this run are how
thoroughly it establishes deadpool as an
unpredictable and competent foe for any
and all superhero characters he
encounters in this run he spends a lot
of time bumping into the larger marvel
universe that he's usually straight away
from got crossovers with x-men wolverine
the dark avenger spider-man captain
america hulk and moore it's not the
first time he's met any of these guys
but it's the first time he's been around
them at length and allowed them to
really get to know him
the main focus of this run is deadpool
examining his suicidal tendencies and
depression as well as why he tends to
push people away that get close to him i
find the crossovers and more
introspective character-driven stuff
really fascinating but at times the
sense of humor in this book starts to
skirt the line of meme pool and i can
understand why a lot of people are very
irritated by this run it's not for
everyone but i wouldn't say you should
skip it either way
this is also when deadpool's popularity
first started to spike after
oh god and he had like four ongoings at
once for the first time deadpool team up
is pretty much exactly what it sounds
like nothing important happens there but
deadpool merck with a mouth is a great
13 issue miniseries that has some ties
to marvel zombies and does the hero
teaming up with his multiverse variants
thing before dan slot spider-verse came
out
now
after all that
read these pages of that annual
i know this is a mess but i want you to
understand what the hell this text box
is instead of guessing because no one
knew what it was supposed to be for a
while or why it randomly disappeared if
you read it in this order
it's gonna make a lot more sense i
promise from here deadpool's stuff gets
really easy to follow jerry duggan and
brian possain's 2013 deadpool runs for
43 issues then reboots with marvel
secret wars and starts over in 2016.
it's uh it's the other secret wars where
um all the universes like slammed into
each other
uh so they could cancel all the ultimate
universe books except miles because he
was the only one that was really worth
keeping this is where great strides were
taken to change up the deadpool's status
quo he really starts facing bigger and
more dangerous threats he starts really
earning the respect of other heroes and
eventually he becomes a member of the
avengers in this run as well as
discovering he's a father
wade has been trying to break through
from a hated bad guy for so many years
into a beloved hero and this run is
really when he gets to that tipping
point and it finally happens
it's weird to finally see him start to
be successful he makes friends he has
family he's loved and famous and this
series finally gives us an answer that's
satisfying for why his backstory is so
convoluted
uh there is no answer wade's memory
memories failing from being given memory
erasing drugs for years on end and
weapon x has still been experimenting on
him the entire time every time he's
recollected his past has been
inconsistent as a result of him not
actually knowing his past himself
sometimes he's just kind of making
things up or confusing it with other
people's memories unlike the movie's
clear-cut and streamlined version of it
everything about deadpool before the day
he puts on this costume is kind of a
mystery now and any one or all of these
stories may be completely incorrect
he's sort of like the superhero version
of the joker in that way his backstory
is multiple choice even though this run
spends a lot of time letting deadpool
finally get some substantial wins
it also gives him his biggest downfall
so far his mercenary organization falls
apart because he's a terrible boss and a
selfish jerk
and then the 2016 run changes titles to
the despicable deadpool as he joins up
with the evil hydra captain america that
made everyone mad and he slowly but
surely ruins every personal relationship
he has in the book
it's tragic and frustrating and sad
because so much progress was made
but the book ends with a hard reset
where he erases his own memory again
to right around the ending of the daniel
way run so all of this
might as well have not happened i mean
it's all good stuff but
damn
even though the character's popularity
and pop culture consciousness is at an
all-time high
his books have struggled since this
decision the scotty young deadpool run
tried to be light on story and heavy on
manic fun with a tone more similar to
the movies
which is why this and works for money
vol 2 suddenly make wade and negasonic
teenage warhead friends even though
they've never talked before ever
look here's colossus that guy that
deadpool has never hung out with but it
happened in the movie so you gotta have
it just as this one was closing on on
finally doing a heavier story with
mephisto trying to get revenge on dp for
events from the dug and run the book was
cancelled and all of it was rushed out
in the last few issues thus it abruptly
ends and leaves that story feeling like
a dud
this is like
10 issues of stuff that happens in like
30 pages and it's just
insane
i really don't like this run and i don't
think there's really anything in here
you'd be missing except some brief
appearances of wade's daughter ellie
but like
all you gotta know is that he remembered
she exists that's that's it after that
is the 2019 series which ran for 10
issues
where deadpool becomes king of an island
full of monsters and it's just
meh
boy he really fell off recently that
series ended in january 2021 and he
hasn't had an ongoing sense after like
30 straight years of consistent books
there's hardly anything sure there's
been little mini series here and there
but the main book is kinda dead for now
what happened he used to clear 60 issues
easily but now he can't last 15 before
the book is rebooted with an entirely
new creative team why is he suddenly
disappeared
oh wait it's because he doesn't have a
movie coming out for another few years
and marvel now treats these books as
advertisements for the mcu at least he's
gonna be a side character in the new
wolverine book on weed day but like
that's not a solo book so
while you're waiting for more deadpool
books let's give an honorable mention to
all the extra stuff that's not
necessarily important to continuity
but it's just some deadpool to get your
fix you get the spider-man deadpool run
that was written by joe kelly starts off
really solid then gets a little less
interesting once kelly leaves the book
and new writers come in
uncanny avengers has deadpool as a main
member of the uh
like second avengers team they had two
at once for some reason
and uh you know it's pretty good
he was in thunderbolts for a little
while with agent venom and punisher so
that was like [ __ ] awesome i love
those characters check that one out that
one's good uh elektra and punisher go on
a date and it's funny cullen bunn has
been writing deadpool miniseries
for ages and there's so many of them
that they almost form their own run
there are a lot of scattered stories set
in elseworlds like deadpool's trilogy of
killing things the duology of deadpool
and the zombie apocalypse and some
dubiously canon books about him hanging
out in secret wars or being temporarily
a host for venom
here are some of my favorite books from
the cullen bunn stuff because his
stories tend to be a bit hit or miss all
right well that's uh uh
that's like kind of everything up until
now i mean everything that you need to
know there's you know a billion deadpool
appearances but that's the the important
stuff while it's not every deadpool
story ever published it's a good list to
get all the major parts of the character
in your mind i tried to just give enough
information about each series so you can
make an informed decision about where
you want to start i knock something over
on my desk you can make an informed
decision about where you want to start
and what sorts of stories with him you
want to read let me know if you like
this format and if i should do other
videos on other characters whose entire
backlog i've read up on over the years
you can find all of these in trade
paperback format now at your local comic
shop or shop for them online pretty
easily so be sure to support the
industry comixology has been nuked to
hell and back by amazon so
also probably complain about that a lot
online until they fix that but maybe
physical sales for him spike up a little
we can finally get some more deadpool
books back
i just i don't want four or five of them
at once again because that's rough on
the whole wallet
[Music]
[Music]
you